wir brauchen eine massive krone
entschuldigung welle im deutschen
journalismus
der grund wie andere meinungen
hierzulande bei vielen medien bei vielen
journalisten den letzten jahren
ausgegrenzt wurde war einfach nicht
richtig man darf fehler machen aber ich
finde dann sollte man sich entschuldigen
eine kurze kostprobe bei mit zwei
statements der ard swr journalist
reinhard becker sagte zitat all diesen
spinnern und corona kritikern sei gesagt
es wird keine normalität mehr geben wie
vorher als politikchef nikolaus blome
den sogar noch weiter als er sagte ich
hingegen möchte an dieser stelle
ausdrücklich um gesellschaftlich im
nachteile für all jene ersuchen die
freiwillig auf eine impfung verzichten
mögen die gesamte republik mit dem
finger auf sie zeigen weder regierung
noch journalismus sind und februar und
ihren spahn hatte recht als er sagte wir
werden einander viel verzeihen müssen
aber dafür muss man ja auch erstmal um
entschuldigung bitten